Okay. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and today we're going to tell you is an old story.
It's about 70 years old,
but it's not really as old as that at all because you will notice
that it hasn't ended and it comes to us from reporter Karen Duffin. Yeah. Okay.
All right. So where to start? I mean, do you have a sense of where to start?
I feel like I could blame. Well,
I can blame this on my dad and that's the house I grew up in. Just so you know.
Oh, right. Well that was my, my bedroom window.
This is Karen and her dad looking at pictures of his childhood home.
He grew up in this tiny town in Idaho called Aberdeen at all Aberdeen.
I forgot how much on a potato farm.
He loves to talk about the farm like he thinks we saw live on a farm,
the garden. That's pretty cool.
So we were talking one day left the records and he mentions very casually as if
it's like something we all know. He says, yeah.
Back when we had Nazi prisoners of war working on our farm and I was like,
timeout. What? Really? That's what he said. It was just parents theoretical.
Yeah, it was totally like, yeah, we're picking potatoes and then yeah,
the Nazi prisoners of war were helping us sorta remember how old I was just by
how tall the guards were. They were very tall.
He was only three or four at the time. Very, very tall.
Do you know if there were like dozens of prisoners or just like a handful? Oh,
there was a bunch I saying I didn't even know there were prisoners of war Nazi
preventive war in America ever. Yeah, me neither. Oh, okay. Yeah.
So that was the, so after I talked to my dad,
I ended up calling this historian Kathy Kirkpatrick,
cause I wanted to know was this just an Aberdeen thing? No.
Like you were talking about Idaho.
She told me in Idaho alone this branch camps in Aberdeen and Blackfoot and
Emmett and Holly Lane, Idaho Falls, there were 23 different camps.
Generally you had prisoners that were in churches, tent cities and Paul Rodeo,
ground dormitories, high school gyms, sugar city,
and this was the case all across the country.
The only state that did not have prisoners of war was Vermont.
Wow. At the maximum we had over 371,000 Germans,
51,000 Italians in 5,000 Japanese,
almost half a million people. Oh my God. Nobody know this.
I don't even remember. It doesn't even like strike a little cord. That may be,
I once learned about it in junior high school. No, this was not talked about.
We just don't talk about it. We just don't. I think we don't,
I don't know,
but today we are going to talk about it but not just because it's a cool
historical thing but because it raises a question. Breaking news,
this nuna stunning report looking into how the CIA interrogated detainees,
the question that on top secret interrogation with torture reports or even
suggested treatment and Abu Ghraib, Regan views by American soldiers,
Guantanamo Bay that we are still trying to answer today,
which is you know when you capture an enemy soldier taken out of the battle,
out of the fight, how should you treat that person?
And if both sides have agreed to follow certain rules and one side doesn't,
what do you do?
And interesting thing is that 70 years ago this question was playing out in this
really dramatic way. In all of these towns across America,
there were about 200 base camps that were huge.
They were like up to 8,000 people. And by the way,
that's like 70 times the size of Guantanamo Bay currently.
In any case, as she was researching,
Karen started to zoom into one camp in particular.
So this is really illustrative of what happened.
There's this one camp in Aliceville, Alabama.
It's this tiny town of like 1500 people,
but the camp has 6,000 people. Wow. It's like four times the size of the town.
Yeah. So I went and interviewed a bunch of people, guards, prisoners,
locals from Aliceville and it was quite a day.
That's Thomas Sweet.
He worked in Aliceville and he told me that the day that the prisoners came
through, a thousand of them came at first and the police were like,
nobody is allowed on the street.
But of course when word got out that the first train blowed was coming,
everybody rushed out on the street that day. The train come in,
there wasn't supposed to be any challenge people. But uh, of course there was,
everybody was sad. The road was laying with his from three years old up there,
people 70 years old.
So these voices are from an oral history project that was recorded in 1994 about
the prison camp in Aliceville.
So the climb the lumber pile so that we could see them when they got off the
train. So everybody's super nervous
because they have these images in their head. In my mind,
just like a lot of people now, it's real.
They didn't know what kind of devils where we was going to get off of that
train. You guys with Horn boiler head.
So these prisoners that were sent to Aliceville were actually part of Rommel's
Africa corps and these guys were the most feared of Hitler's
fighters. There were supposed to be the elite.
He told Nazi Superman then Nazi superman. Right? So the train pulls up,
they stopped right on the main highway,
doors open,
and then hundreds and hundreds of German soldiers get out and they were marching
with that German march and they're singing their military songs at German.
Tell us about what it was like when,
what she thought when they got off the train, the train.
What did they look like? Do they have on uniform? Oh yes.
So when you listened to the oral histories,
it's really clear that this was a really complicated moment for the people in
Aliceville at Vaco. The allies for were scared today.
I didn't know what I was going to be mad at them when they first come in and or
what. But when I actually knew we just a bunch of quip kids sham with
a feeling of uh,
a concern for in our hearts, for them all. I see them.
There was nothing but a bunch of young kids.
How young they will haggard looking,
washed up and meet remanded and some of they maggots.
Oh, just grapes. You could tell they'd been through a rough time. Uh, it was,
it was hopeful for us. That sounds cool. Para,
he was one of the prisoners stepping out of the train that day.
He'd been drafted into the army against his well captured in North Africa.
And then he was sent to America in the bottom of this big cargo ship on the new
one room, the crowded 700 people.
You couldn't even sit. There was no toilet.
Of course she had only 13 of boxes over with full soaked with urine.
It was helpful. Was a low food trip. Yeah.
And you kind of had to feel sorry for them. But on that other hand,
and you hear this too, in the oral histories,
the people in Alice filler thinking, these are Nazis.
These are the men who are killing our son. Well, you know,
I had three brothers I would say is at the same time,
so we didn't like them. That's just the way we felt.
Okay, so there's that question in people's mind,
and this is playing out all across the country. Here's the enemy at your mercy.
What do you do? How do you treat them? They're in your hands. Nobody's watching.
You can do whatever you want with them at that point in theory. But in practice,
we'll actually, this was a significant moment for the world.
I mean 14 years before a bunch of countries had gotten together and they'd made
up rules for exactly this kind of moment.
In 1929 at Geneva,
long before Hitler and his partners began to eye the real estate of the world.
That was an international conference here,
a nation solemnly promise to uphold the rules covering the treatment of
prisoners of war.
Oh, it was a series of do's and don'ts.
That's a story in Arnold Kramer. He's a professor at Texas A. And. M.
Some of the rules he says are pretty basic that women and children should be
protected. So you had to give prisoners a certain amount of
food and alerts are entitled to the same quality rations,
loving and living quarters as aren't afforded our own truck.
And then there's rules about medical attention, labor. Well,
did you need a convention? Says yes, you can use people for Labor.
Cathy Kirkpatrick. Again, you also should be paying people for Labor. Okay,
the rate of payment was 80 cents a day.
So the Geneva Conventions are this attempt to kind of civilize the most
uncivilized thing, which is war. You'll see the f,
the first world war was so horrific.
Hundreds of thousands of prisoners died in POW camp.
There were no real regulations with regard to prisoners.
Sides did almost anything they wanted.
So the Geneva Conventions of 1929 was an attempt to kind of set things right,
because people just couldn't fathom another war to end wars.
We were well trained in the Geneva Convention. That's Thomas Sweet. Again,
he was actually one of the guards at camp and what he said is that even before
the POW is arrived at the Geneva Conventions were drilled into their heads.
They had lectures,
the rules were posted in the rec hall and in the officers' club where you had
to, the prisoners had to be treated the same, uh, as you would,
uh, your own fail or soldiers, which sounds kind of basic,
but for somebody like Hahn's who stepping off this train and wondering how is he
going to be treated? It was, I should say it was
assault of a heaven.
[inaudible]
when I got into the, the badge at all been laid out,
that fresh clean,
they had a towels and shape and equipment for each one on each, uh,
each one's bonk.
Prisoners washed up and then the guards opened up the cafeteria.
Then we got to eat good things.
This is Walter Fel tilter he was another prisoner at Ellisville.
We got the piece of white bread,
you American white bread and we got peanut butter. I didn't know about it,
what peanut was and it chased it one for one level.
It was the best one I ever had. And I always been,
I think on the which times, and I think on peanut butter.
Yeah. And here's the funny thing. As you look into this,
you start to realize that we're not just following the Geneva Conventions,
the letter of the law. We're going above and beyond. And according to Hahns,
what started out as a great thing,
getting all this food ended up to be kind of a problem.
The voice came to me every day.
Please tell them we don't want to have so much hem and the sash.
And came to me who heard that and said,
don't tell the captain that you're going to throw it away. No, no, no, no, no.
Take teeth and make a hole in the sand and put it in the sand.
So they buried the hand and a lot of it varied.
A lot of the hem because we didn't know what to do with it. Wow.
And they also didn't like corn,
but they kept [inaudible] getting corn and so they buried corn and then they get
caught because corn starts growing. [inaudible].
Everyone's like, wait a minute, there's bad corn hiding.
Okay.
Within two months they have an orchestra.
Within a year they have three orchestras. This is a pow led orchestras.
Yes, yes. And they're being given instruments. They're making instruments.
The locals are donating instruments, the YMCAs,
giving them instruments before through the mud,
young and [inaudible] in the field. They opened a school,
Hey, hold on, wait, wait, hold on baby.
You can learn anything from pottery to like mathematics,
almost any language you want to learn.
So,
and they set up correspondence programs with the local universities.
You could credit, they had soccer again,
just about every day they drew big crowds. They had a newspaper.
Their newspaper was called the fence to guest and it had like poetry fist. Yes,
you're right. They,
they also did a lot of theatrical productions and sometimes there were regular
art shows. So this is where things get a little bit strange.
On December 18th there was another art exhibition.
This is a woman named Ellen Vander's whose father was a pow at the camp.
And here she's reading from his diary
12 [inaudible].
That means Hitler had sent $12,572 to open the art exhibition in
Camp V. Okay.
Wait, she's saying that wait, Hitler sent money to the camp for an art thing.
Yup. Wow.
The dirt while we're fighting it. Are He sending money? Yeah.
While we're fighting Hitler, while we're fighting Hitler. That's really strange.
It's fun. I go on the
[inaudible]. Oh yeah.
Coming up the fence. Guests are on fence, be buried.
Amazon buried and the Nazis next door began.
An argument that we are still having
to this day show
[inaudible].
I'm Tammy pate from Spencer, Indiana.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
okay.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
What have you got invest in our planet while also investing in your financial
future? Think about that. Our resources are diminishing.
Our population is growing. Companies solving today's biggest challenges.
We'll beat tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth companies working towards clean water when
usable energy and green technology.
It's a market opportunity you can feel good about.
You get a $50 bonus when you open your account@swellinvesting.com slash
Radiolab.
Okay.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by progressive progressive offers you tons of ways to save
on insurance, starting with building and savings,
like discounts for being a safe driver.
You can also save for getting a quote online. And when you bundle home and auto,
you can even save more. In fact,
customers who switched to progressive can save an average of $668
a year on car insurance. Start a quote online and start saving today.
Visit progressive.com
Yay. I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab and uh,
get back to our story. Here's Karen Duffin. Um, okay. So, so, okay.
With Hitler's a Christmas gift to the art show and the ham and the bands and all
that stuff, did people in the,
in the outside the camp know what was going on inside? You know,
and once they start,
so I think it was in 1943 was the point at which we started realizing we're
running out of American men to do labor and we look around and we're like,
well actually we have quite a few men who might be able to do some work here.
Love them. Prisoners worked uh,
on farms down there picking cotton peanuts.
So some of the farmers would bring them in the house for lunch,
they would drink with them, they were drunk. They,
there's some really funny stories of like, I was probably moonshine.
The prisoners getting drunk with the farmers and then they get in trouble cause
they come home late.
One of the biggest things that the word apartments says when they start sending
the men out is like if you, if you make friends with these ws,
it's against the rules, but they do it all the time.
Anybody Fall in love with anybody? Oh yeah. [inaudible]
I mean not a lot, but it definitely happened.
So as these prisoners are out in the community and they're forming friendships,
few of them are falling in love.
Where it starts to get out about how they're being treated. And meanwhile,
across America there's rationing and so when they learn that the pure W's are
getting food that they might not be getting a lot of the American public,
they get pissed.
No, the other [inaudible],
especially this radio guy, Walter Winchell who sort of made this his cause,
they call him the rush Limbaugh of World War II. Was He that well known one?
Walter Winchell was one of the most famous reporters in America.
He spoke like that telegram, Waukegan,
[inaudible]. He spoke in this funny nasal voice. Oh, we got,
that's exactly what it sounds like. Our radio dispatch from Prague. In any case,
when he finds out about the Nazi POW program,
Walter Winchell just starts to rant.
The United States army caters to the Nazis as no, they were king.
They get more food than our soldiers get.
Pony radio luxuries and all sorts of leniency beyond imagination.
And he would do this week after week,
wait, Kako is over here.
We'll pay of any Nazis to catch up and fucking up on stage.
[inaudible] bacon or chicken lit up.
People start writing articles in the New York Times, the Chicago Tribune,
the Boston Globe, it's citizens start flooding the war department with letters.
I know, sir, that y'all YMC a wall, prisoners aid does all it can,
can make Nazi war prisoners all the head comment about.
And in the meantime, according to Thomas Sweet inside the camp,
some of these prisoners are starting to get kind of bold for a couple of nights.
I cut out swat stickers and took
a kite and uh,
we're flying the kite and had dishwash stickers in a box underneath the kite
with a string that down to the ground. And uh,
they handed the Strang to one of the, one of the guards and said,
pull this string. And when I pulled the string,
the trap door open on the gadget they had made and all these swastika started
falling all over, all over the camp. And in Aliceville too, in the towns,
people started calling the base mad about that,
add to that we don't have enough men to guard a lot of these camps. So,
so the prisoners are starting to get more and more control of the camp grows.
Moose had the, Ron was a camp and in some cases the Nazi hardliners would,
would start to torment the non Nazis. They would threaten them,
they might beat them up.
There were even a couple of murders who was not a Nazi in side of these camps.
Um, if you had been drafted but you didn't, you weren't idle ideologically.
I see.
So the perception that's coming out of these camps is that we've created these
hotels on American soil. We're Nazis.
Kids start radicalizing and people get so mad that there's actually a
congressional investigation into the coddling of prisoners of war.
So I spent a lot of time at the national archives trying to get to like,
all right, what are the arguments? And here's kind of how it went.
You have this congressman on one side, Richard heartless,
and he's saying you're coddling them.
Congressman Holler from Arizona called the Nazi prisoners in the United States.
Hi Brett.
And on the other side you have the guy who's now running the prisoner of war
program, archer alert. And he's basically saying, no,
not all them.
He says, we're just following the Geneva Conventions.
And the reason that he gave was the same reason that Joe Biden would give almost
60 years later.
And there's a reason why we signed these treaties to protect my son in the
military. We are torture them. They'll touch your up reciprocity.
That's why we have these treaties.
So when Americans are captured,
they are not tortured. That's the reason case.
Anybody forgets it. That the reason,
one problem though,
just one month after that hearing in 1944
on, um, the defense of American prisoners battle,
the machine guns of our enemies
news breaks that 84 American soldiers,
prisoners of war now in Germany are gunned down after they surrendered.
Well, a week later,
they're frozen body and the mango found found where they fell.
We then go on to liberate American soldiers from POW camps in Germany and we
find misery. Nothing like Ellisville American
prisoners of war report in human hospital conditions.
Walter windchill gets back on the airwaves, right?
The premise of the United States,
you said, look, reciprocity hasn't worked. Our generosity.
I have not been reciprocated. And olive oils
were not treated the same. There's nothing wrong.
I believe protected as much by [inaudible]. And by the one side of the room,
a few months later, things get even worse.
It was impossible to fully realize the horror of the Nazi concentration gaps.
We started going into concentration camps.
Incredible truth that man had indeed some below the level of animal [inaudible],
the pretty lean started seeing what the Germans had done,
what the Nazis have done. Both kinds of dead bodies were piled everywhere.
Most never having received the dignity of burial.
But what was even more frightening were the living dead left behind.
[inaudible]
so congress decides to hold a second investigation into the treatment of
prisoners. But this time it's real soul searching. I mean,
we had just seen the full horrors of the Holocaust. So we're thinking, you know,
anything we do to these guys at this point they deserve.
And we've also realized we're not really getting reciprocity.
So we don't really have a practical reason to treat them well anymore.
So at this point, the question has really become,
do we continue to be good even when we're not getting anything in return?
And the kind of amazing thing to me is that we decide, yeah,
we're going to stick to the Geneva Conventions.
Archer alert who runs the POW program at this point. He gets up and he says,
we are not going to lower ourselves to Nazi standards.
We are not going to let the enemy decide who we are as a country.
And that argument stuck. Yeah.
I think that most people associated with the prison camp a experience that's
historian Arnold Kramer again, felt that we treated them well,
not because they treated Howard as well,
but that we are decent people and we probably would have done this anyway.
Well, what makes on the American is not any special precious sort of blood,
but the tradition we have inherited, it's tradition, not blood,
but pattern is the way we think and act and feel.
Oh, there's a great belief that, uh,
we have a special mission, uh, and we have a special history.
This is David Goldfield. He's a historian at UNC Charlotte.
That's the ideal, but no,
I mean you don't.
You only have to look at the treatment of Japanese Americans during World War
II.
He says, don't forget, right, is we're giving the Nazis massive amounts of Ham.
We're also rounding up tens of thousands of Japanese American citizens,
citizens,
and we're throwing them into these cramped camps that are way worse than
Ellisville. And if you ask David,
why are we treating the Germans so much better? They look like us.
Who's people look alright? The mailman, the farmer,
they all look pretty much like the floats back home.
The major reason race, the Germans were white.
They seemed familiar that there was a connection between the German POW
[inaudible] and the folks in the American south,
not only because of the ethnicity of the Germans,
not only because of their economic benefit to the region.
David told us that he's looked at the historical documents and he thinks the
German laws against the Jews were essentially copied from the Mississippi black
coats. We couldn't confirm that they were literally copies, but there are both.
There are similarities and a bunch of official Nazi documents from that time.
Priests, southern race laws.
So there was already a connection between the American south and that's the
Germany. This is the most horrifying thing I've, I mean,
is it really true that like all the niceness was just a perverse form of racism?
Well,
I would say racism plays an enormous role in why Japanese citizens were interned
in the first place. I don't think there's any question about that.
That's Paul Springer. He's a military historian, Maxwell Air Force Base,
Alabama. He's not quite sure that race explains all of this. He says,
you know what?
You've got to be careful because you're comparing treatment of citizens to
treatment of prisoners of war. And that's different.
It's not a fair comparison for the case of,
of why you treat the German POW is better. Well, um,
because they're prisoners of war, the Japanese POW is,
were also exceedingly well treated.
They were treated much better than the Japanese citizens of the United States.
And I think that's the comparison that's probably more interesting is why did
you treat enemy soldiers from Japan better than you treated citizens of the
United States of Japanese heritage?
And he says very simply that with prisoners of war,
it's because we had a rule governing international law,
like the Geneva Conventions.
There's no similar law at that time that says what you can and can't do towards
your civilian populations. That's interesting.
So it's like maybe we're not racist or noble, but both,
and it's the rules that allow us to be our better selves.
Maybe. Here's what I take from this. I think that in a time of war,
it's incredibly difficult to be good to your enemy.
It's not just about aspiring to be good at this American ideal.
It's about having 97 really nitpicky, tiny,
tedious rules to tell you exactly what you can do and what you can't do because
it would just be so easy to not be the person that you want to be in.
That moment does
kind of make you think back to February of 2002 good afternoon,
I have an announcement to make.
I'm President Bush today has decided that the Geneva Convention will apply to
the Taliban detainees, but not to the al Qaeda international [inaudible]
terrorists.
The president has maintained the United States his commitment to the principles
of the Geneva Convention while recognizing that the convention simply does not
cover every situation in which people may be captured or detained by military
forces. As we see in Afghanistan today says John,
already, what you're telling us is that the Taliban prisoners,
detainees at Guantanamo will not get any more protections than they already are
given under the Geneva Convention.
And what you seem to be telling us is that the al-Qaida detainees will give,
you know, there is no change in the protections they will be provided.
They are usually,
they have always been treated consistent with the principles of the Geneva
Convention,
which means it will be treated well if you're looking for anything that will not
happen as a result of this announcement is that they will not receive stipends
from the American taxpayers.
They will not receive the musical instruments courtesy of the United States
military. They would have received those had they been declared pow.
They will continue to be treated well because they're in the custody of America.
But the concern, the debate here was about if you don't do it here,
then US soldiers could be mistreated abroad. Isn't that correct?
And so isn't that a big,
a big motivation here is sure that US whole just get the same kind of treatment?
Yes sir.
Important for all nations throughout the world to treat any prisoners well.
And that is something that I says always expects and United States always does.
We have time for one more question and then there's a, we'll pull it back.
Hold it David. We'll get it. David,
we'll get one more and then we'll cover ahead. Wasn't this an important concern?
I understand what the expectations are,
but it was important for this administration to be able to say, look,
we want to be able to protect our soldiers and similar situations down the line.
And if we, if we don't accord,
if we don't know if we're afforded a probably just under the Geneva Convention
that our solutions could be a girl. Dude,
I was not in the ass who deliberations were various issues were raised.
So I really, there's no way I can accurately answer that question. Go ahead.
Devon forces. They don't, they often do not wear uniforms.
They often do not carry their weapons outwardly. If they were captured,
they wouldn't use reserve in terms of the Geneva Convention,
apply to all those terms. Speak for themselves. Okay. Thank you everybody.
[inaudible]
thank you to reporter Karen Duffin and also producer Kelsey pageant.
This is such a long and involved reporting process. Big props to them.
Special thanks to Sam,
the filmmaker who collected all those Aliceville oral histories.
Andrew John Gilliam and Mary Best Bellucci current and former Aliceville museum
directors, Ruth Beaumont Cook,
who wrote a great book about the Alice Allisonville camp and Nancy way Mack for
research help. Now I'm jet at Boom Rod. I remember Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.